you're not making as much money as you
want to make because you're not getting
as many leads as you need to have to
sell stuff to and you're probably not
getting as many leads as you need
because you're not giving away enough
free stuff I can assure you that if it
actually costs you money it usually will
be valued at a significantly higher
percentage to the marketplace so sure
you can have a free pdf sure you can
have a digital video series but normally
unless it's exceptional people aren't
going to value that because that's what
a lot of people do sometimes giving away
actual free work that you will incur
cost on a lot more people will take you
up on and if you do the math you will
ultimately make more money and this is
the difference between small business
owners and big business owners they can
incur calculated cost Upfront for a much
bigger back end